bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis ravi
d'être là pour partager cette
expérience avec vous nous sommes en
novembre 2016 il est 23 heures la nuit
est déjà tombée sur nantes et je
reprends ma voiture seul après avoir
passé une délicieuse soirée avec des
amis mes enfants de 8 12 et 16 ans mme
attendent tranquillement à la maison
jusque là la vie normale d'une chefs de
famille monoparentale
jusqu'à ce moment où sur le chemin du
retour je me retrouve par un concours de
circonstances malheureux à devoir passer
toute une nuit en garde à vue au
commissariat
à 500 mètres de chez moi oui moi la ccil
le petit bout de femme que vous avez
devant vous c'est retrouver à passer
toute une nuit derrière les barreaux en
garde à vue alors je vais vous raconter
comment dans cette cellule de prison de
cinq mètres carrés
j'ai accédé un grand moment de liberté
12 heures enfermé dans cinq mètres
carrés c'est court et long à la fois
vous pouvez imaginer le scénario va très
vite
les questions se bousculent dans ma tête
qui va prévenir a mis nu mes enfants qui
va emmener ma petite à l'école demain
matin comment vais-je assurer mon
intervention prévue à 9h demain avec
douze clients importants je suis prise
de panique je crie à l'injustice jardin
que quelqu'un vienne me libérer je veux
que ce mauvais film s'arrête
personne ne vient
je décide de faire un état des lieux je
suis assise sur un matelas en caoutchouc
avec pour seul accessoire une couverture
de survie à côté de moi il y à un
urinoir séparées par une cloison d'un
mètre trente deux auteurs devant moi un
mur rempli d'écriture et puis je vois
mes voisins de cellule au travers de la
porte là il semble tout à fait
s'accommoder du lieu certains crient
d'autres crash d'autres tapent à la
porte en espérant se faire entendre ou
quelle délicieuse soirée alors dans tout
ce tumulte toute cette cacophonie
màj c'est de prendre un peu de hauteur
et une question me vient à ce moment là
qu'elle est ma part de liberté aussi
infime soit elle enfermée dans cette
cellule de 5 mètres carrés et bien c'est
durant ces quelques heures
d'emprisonnement que j'ai pris toute la
mesure du chemin parcouru ces dix
dernières années afin de mieux gérer mon
stress je m'étais intéressé aux vastes
champs de la connaissance de soi du
développement personnel mes premiers
apprentissages et bien provenait d'une
lecture dans laquelle était écrit pour
atteindre un degré élevé de conscience
de soi on doit être prêt à tout lire et
le malaise suscité par des émotions
possiblement négative - à l'époque mon
malaise mes angoisses mes peurs
j'essayais à tout prix de les éviter
petit mon père ne cessez de me dire tu
occupes à de la marque du vélo aux
pédales pédaler et quoi qu'il arrive ne
pas s'arrêter parce que si je m'arrêtais
d'une certaine façon
eh bien c'était la chute assurée alors
très tôt j'ai compris qu'il fallait que
j'arrête de fuir qu'il fallait que
j'accueille ses émotions pour éviter
qu'elle ne me mène par le bout du nez
alors dans ma cellule je décide de me
tourner vers le malaise que je ressens
je prends conscience du sentiment
d'injustice qui m'envahit de mes
inquiétudes des pas du policier dans le
couloir des cris des personnes qui
s'entête à vouloir sortir de l'eau
d'heure de l'urinoir à côté de moi des
mots écrits sur les murs la sensation du
béton du caoutchouc la couverture de
survie
et puis cette lumière éblouissante
constamment allumée qui m'enlève toute
notion de temps alors je suis la fille
j'ai avec eric corps qui ne demande qu'à
courir loin ce besoin de courir loin de
ne plus vivre ce que j'étais en train de
vivre m'a ramené à la perte d'un enfant
quelques années auparavant
ma fille a été victime d'une mort subite
non expliquée à l'âge de 6 mois et
c'était injuste insupportable
ma plus grande préoccupation à l'époque
c'était comment fait-on pour vivre et ne
pas survivre après un tel drame
eh bien j'avais posé là qu est la
question à la pédo psychiatre de
l'hôpital qui m'avait répondu vous avez
entendu parler du moment présente cette
réponse m'avait intrigué je m'étais
intéressé de plus en plus à ce moment
présent mais sans jamais vraiment saisir
jusqu'à ce que je découvre une manière
de m'exercer à revenir dans le moment
présent il s'agissait de la méditation
de pleine conscience autrement appelée
la mindfulness
les chercheurs ont observé d'une séance
de méditation était faite de phases
constitué de 4 6 1 le vagabondage
dépensé 2 la prise de conscience de la
distraction
3 la réorientation de la tension
4 le retour à la concentration mois en
pratiquant j'ai réalisé à quel point
j'étais plongé la plupart du temps dans
la distraction c'est vrai même effrayé
au début ça vous est jamais arrivé à
vous ruminer le passé de faire des
choses de manière très automatique de
vous perdre dans vos pensées sans aucun
rapport avec l'expérience que vous vivez
mois eh bien c'était tout à la fois et
très souvent alors dans ma cellule je
décide de faire une marche méditative
ou alors j'ai quelques heures à passer
là je suis en train de cultiver mon
attention de l'entraîner à rester dans
le moment présent dans ce qui se passe
dans ce qui est en train de se passer
plutôt que de fuir basique un bien
pourtant en tant que maman et femme
d'affaires hyperactive
c'est la chose la plus difficile que
j'ai eu à faire dans ma vie et la
présence dans mes pas dans mes pieds
dans ma respiration me permet de ramener
le calme mental d'arrêter le flou dans
lequel je suis plongée et puis le faire
de l'espace pour y voir plus clair et en
créant cet espace mental et bien je peux
mieux voir ce qui est sous mon contrôle
et ce qui ne l'est pas je ne suis plus
collée à ses émotions ses sentiments qui
m'envahissait alors il ya une image qui
lui ce phénomène de libération de
l'espace et je souhaite la partager avec
vous voici un point qui représente ce
qui peut parfois envahir tout le champ
de notre attention
qu'il s'agisse d'une émotion très
prenante comme la peur d'une
préoccupation pour l'un de nos proches
d'un dossier très en retard que nous
devons remettre qui n'avance pas nous
avons tendance à être coulés dessus nous
avons tendance prendre la tête avec elle
tourner dans tous les sens à vouloir le
mettre de côté pour plus tard vous même
en faire des insomnies et bien la
présence attentive permet de faire de
l'espace permet de faire de la place
autour de ce point de cette
préoccupation de façon à ce qu'ils
n'envahissent plus tout le champ de la
tension il y a un champ plus vaste au
tour qui se dégage
cela permet de faire un pas de côté de
trouver des ressources d'autres options
qui n'aurait pas été rendue possible
autrement
alors le point ne disparaît pas pour
autant
mais il n'occupe plus la même place
envahissante et c'est en changeant notre
rapport avec ce point en nous mettant à
la juste distance en faisant un pas de
côté que la perspective change et que
nous pouvons y répondre autrement de
manière plus consciente à redon et
cellule je repense à ce point comment
créer de l'espace dans cette situation
quel acte conscient je peux poser pour
retrouver ma liberté chérie et bien je
peux simplement relâché la crispation
lâcher cette illusion du contrôle sortir
de ma boîte intérieur accueillir mes
angoisses mes inquiétudes
mon anticipation du pire concernant mes
enfants mes clients ma vie observé cela
est décidé de ne pas suivre ses pensées
qui sont après tout que dépenser
c'est si simple et si difficile à la
fois pourtant il s'agit bien de cela
d'une liberté intérieure plutôt que
d'une liberté de mouvement
voilà liberté de mouvement je la
connaissais bien entre deux avions de
tgv
enchaînant les rendez vous je le croyais
même quand celle là mais la liberté
intérieure
je commence à considérer ma cellule
comme un réel lieu d'apprentissage
je décide de lire tous les maux qui sont
écrit sur le mur je me représente les
personnes qui ont dû les écrire leur
ingéniosité à les écrire car nous sommes
dépourvus de tout suspens celle en
prison puis j'observe le gardien il fait
des allers retours dans le couloir qui
essaye de parler à certains détenus pour
calmer leurs ardeurs
j'observe son quotidien
je me demande ce qui a bien pu l'amener
à choisir ce métier
puis-je amène beaucoup de curiosité pour
l'expérience que je suis en train de
vivre
je ressent soudain une immense liberté
je me sens rempli d'une énergie de vie
très puissante
je redécouvre soudainement ce que ce que
signifie pour moi la liberté dans cette
situation ma liberté intérieure celle
sur laquelle je peux agir
ma situation elle est là la seule
liberté que j'ai c'est le regard que je
vais porter sur cette situation
dans ma cellule rempli de cette énergie
de vie très puissante et bien je réalise
de manière encore plus flagrante qu'il
ya encore pas mal d'endroits dans ma vie
où je me sens pas complètement libre et
que dans ces situations précisément
c'est plus un mouvement de liberté
intérieure qu'il nous faut chercher
plutôt qu'une liberté de mouvement
depuis cet épisode plus que jamais dans
chaque situation où j'ai pu ou pas de
contrôle je me pose cette question
ça serait quoi de me sentir libre dans
cette situation
et pour vous dans votre quotidien
dans votre vie professionnelle ça serait
quoi de vous sentir libre dans chaque
situation
merci
[Applaudissements]